see what happens if we actually do give
it a go with our original example you
define your two pieces or your factors
of your product is U and B in fact I
usually write U and V over the top of my
two things just so I know which one is
which
not that it matters it's symmetrical
excuse me
so if I now consider these if I say dy r
DX is equal to V times u - what's V
times u - in this case it's x times one
like so that's the roof involved so now
I do the u v - well u is x and V dash is
still 1 which thankfully gives us the
result we knew we were supposed to get
in the first place okay questions yep
yep okay so as a quick example before I
get you guys going on the on the
exercises if I ask you asks you to
differentiate this okay let's have a go
at something like this I'll use this one
that okay there we go perfect example
okay
yes of course I could just expand the
whole lot out and then I could just use
this but I want to get out of here
before the Sun sets so instead I will
take it in the form that is right now I
will label I'm going to put my blue one
I will label each of the bits you and
beef you and E and now I'm going to do
the proper terms gives me the product
rule on the basis of what I've defined
as U and V so I'm going to do it like
this sorry V u - here's the the whole
thing right so it's 3x - 1 to the 7th
that's V what's you - in this case 2x
is the first half of the protocol let's
do the second half it's you toes V -
there's you and what's V - in this case
it's actually easy enough that you could
probably do it in your head hmm you've
got to do are the inside and then you do
the outside or actually doesn't matter
which order you do it in what's the
inside derivative it's just three what's
the outside well it's something to the
power of seven so you'd bring the power
down and then you reduce the power by
one seven you for the six do you agree
so this is seven you to the six see what
I did there there's the inside
derivative there's the outside
derivative yes there are too many use
this is where I would say like if this
is you getting a if this is your brain
getting confused with too many different
levels of substitution then you would
have to you have to introduce more
letters you'd have to say well if this
is you and this is V I can't call this
you as well and have to call W or Zed or
something like that okay but I think
this is a sufficiently simple example
that I can get away with what doing that
I could tidy this up just a little bit
more I'll leave this guy out the front I
should put the two X I guess out here
and then here what am I going to get 21
x squared here so make it so it's a bit
of a dog's breakfast but there you go
that'sthat's what happens when you
issues product these two again a little
more complicated in this case you would
be fine to leave your answer in this
form because you've differentiated that
is the derivative almost certainly
though and this will become a little
more clear in the next topics that we're
going on to probably your next step from
here would be to factorize you've
differentiated successfully so if all
you ask to do is differentiate that's it
but more often than not the next step
that you would do
it would require you to fact I suggest
for the sake of it just because we've
got it right here what things can I
factorize out so the 3 X minus 1 to the
power of 6 is an easy thing you can see
so I'll put that out first that's not
the only thing you can factorize our
third to you right
you can also factor a that an X there's
one here to here but I need comments
right so I'll check the X out there
which would leave me with okay let's see
- lots of this and 21 X do great which
again I can simplify a little further 6
X minus 2 plus 21x so that makes it 27 X
yeah and now I think we're done okay so
as I shared for the purposes of ok I'm
having to go to the product of all I'm
just differentiating that's all I've
been asked to do at at this point here
good job well done you're finished ok
but as you will see it's not it's not a
bad idea to practice that further skill
of factorization because it becomes so
useful later